Carnegie Mellon University has a long
history in studying all levels of brain
function going from individual neurons
to networks of neurons to a whole brain
all right so psychology and philosophy
what we're doing in my research group is
to try to understand how large
populations of neurons work together
using novel statistical machine learning
methods and particular questions that
were very interested in right now
involve learning and one of the tools
that we're using to study learning is
brain computer interfaces the university
has a long tradition in using the latest
technologies to understand how the brain
works so a brain computer interface is a
system that reads out neural activity
from individual neurons in the brain and
then translate that neural activity into
movements of a cursor on a computer
screen and hopefully this knowledge will
allow us to develop systems to help
people learn better both for
rehabilitation as well as the novel
aspect of our work to utilize brain
computer interfaces as an experimental
infrastructure to study basic scientific
questions about how the brain works
I believe brain hub is one of the
strongest centers in neuroscience and
computational neuroscience in the world
there are over 120 faculty members who
are involved in some sort of brain
research here at Pittsburg and everyone
is within 10 minutes of walking distance
from each other and this creates a
really vibrant community and I believe
that this is one of the fastest growing
and most exciting places to do brain
research today
you